bueno se trata de una enfermedad grave
como decíamos pero no altamente
infecciosa para los humanos que se sabe
de este brote a elin y tenemos razones
para preocuparnos por ejemplo ya
trascendió que un caso fue detectado en
canadá
y también en los eeuu se han detectado
casos o sea ya se ha visto en varios
países
inglaterra e irlanda en canadá etcétera
y el problema con esta enfermedad es que
hasta 10% de las personas que lo quieren
pueden fallecer o sea es una enfermedad
que puede ser grave en ciertas personas
especialmente en los niños pero como has
dicho tienes no tienes correcto
normalmente no se transmite rápidamente
entre personas pero sí se puede
transmitir entre personas y se puede
transmitir por manera de respiratoria
contacto con líquidos de la otra
personas camas que tienen el virus
encima materiales por ejemplo también lo
puede transmitir pero normalmente éstos
se encuentra en personas que han estado
en contacto con animales silva ticos
especialmente en áfrica en áfrica
central y áfrica occidental donde
existen muchos diferentes tipos de
animales que lo pueden tener esta
infección incluyendo los monos simios
también las ardillas por ejemplo todos
esos animales no pueden tener y es más
en el 2003 y hubo un brote pequeño que
los eeuu precisamente de este virus por
por unos animales unos pequeños que unos
niños tuvieron entonces puede ser
peligroso porque puede afectar los ojos
por ejemplo esta y entonces puede la
persona se puede poner ciega o sea de
verdad es una cosa que se tiene que
prestarle atención que no tiene que
estar de cuenta de esto haremos nuestro
punto muy importante porque no hay cura
para la viruela del mono pero porque si
para la viruela común que fue erradicada
hace décadas y en esta línea me parece
muy importante preguntarle cómo nos
protegemos entonces cómo proteger a la
población
bueno la misma vacuna que se que
erradicó la viruela de seres humanos
también funciona perfectamente bien
contra este virus pero la populación
nuestra actualmente muy pocos de
nosotros tenemos esa vacuna porque se
daba comúnmente hasta más o menos el año
70 1970 depende y si esa enfermedad se
declaró erradicada en 1980 o sea no se
está dando la vacuna pero la vacuna
existía y actualmente por razones de de
de miedo de que algún país hubiera
utilizado el virus de viruela en una
manera agresiva
existen nuevas vacunas que son hasta más
sana y salva y más efectiva que las
originales y funciona contra en la
viruela de mono